hi everyone and welcome to today's live
broadcast future of psychopharmacology
is new treatment innovation that
presented by dr. Stephen stop
I'm Julian Chara blaggards and I'll be
your moderator for today's presentation
you're excited to bring you this
educational Webster and are presented by
laberd's the leading scientific social
networking website and provider of
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
this web seminar is the pre-recorded due
to scheduling conflicts so unfortunately
we won't be offering a live Q&A we
encourage you to email questions to our
speaker he'll do its best to follow up
with you Gmail is SMS tah Mei global
comm also please notice that you will be
viewing the presentation in the slide
window to enlarge slowly don't just
click on the screen icon located on the
lower right if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of the presentation window or use the
Q&A button to let us know that you're
having a problem this is an educational
limit our and thus offers free
continuing education credits after the
webinar is over please click on the see
Ethan located on the bottom left corner
of your webpage and follow the process
of obtaining an credits now I'd like to
introduce dr. Steven stall dr. Steven M
asam received his undergraduate medical
degrees from Northwestern University in
Chicago as a member of the Honors
Program in medical education and his PhD
degree in pharmacology and physiology
from the University of Chicago dr. Saul
has trained in three specialties
internal medicine at the University of
Chicago neurology at the University of
California in San Francisco and
psychiatry at Stanford University he is
a board certified in psychiatry dr.
Stahl has held faculty positions at
Stanford University the University of
California at Los Angeles the Institute
of Psychiatry at London the institute of
neurology London
and currently as agile professor of
psychiatry at the University of
California in San Diego dr. Saul was
also the executive director of clinical
neurosciences at Merck neuroscience
Research Centre in the UK for several
years dr. Styles major interests are
dedicated to producing and disseminating
educational information about diseases
and treatments in psychiatry and
neurology with a special emphasis on
multimedia the Internet
and teaching us how to product each
doctor saw has conducted numerous
research projects during his career
awarded by the National Institute of
Mental Health by the Veterans
Administration and by the pharmaceutical
industry I've heard more than 350
articles and chapters dr. SAW is an
internationally recognized clinician
researcher and teacher in psychiatry
with subspecialty expertise in
psychopharmacology dr. Saul had edited
three books and written for others
including the best-selling textbook
essential pharmacology now in its third
edition and the best-selling clinical
manual essential psychopharmacology
prescribers guide please join me in
welcoming dr. Saul hello everybody it's
great to be here I'm Steve Stahl and the
title of my talk is a future of
psychopharmacology is new treatment
innovation dead well let's hope it's not
but let's find out innovation in
psychopharmacology is dead long live
innovation in psychopharmacology so
what's going on and what's the topic of
this talk well what's going on in our
field is that the priorities of big
pharma have changed and they're shifting
very rapidly and profoundly away from
the central nervous system and
especially from psychiatry we will
explore some of the reasons for that but
we also know that a big driver of that
are what you call failed clinical trials
there are literally littering the
landscape what do I mean by that even
drugs that we know that work
don't work in clinical trials what's
going on it's a broken clinical trial
apparatus and so we don't know exactly
the causes of this but if you can't tell
if the drug works you're not going to
actually try to even look and that's a
little bit of what's happened the other
thing is that even if you had a drug
that worked if it's only an iterative
stepwise improvement or a me-too agent
as has been characteristic of much of
the innovation of the 1990s by the 21st
century now it's not getting reimbursed
even in the United States which is
traditionally had a lot of liberal
reimbursement we now even here have
aggressive cost controls and if you
listen to the debates of the primaries
that are going on in both parties you
can see that the aggressive cost
controls may actually ramp up even
higher after the general election and a
big problem is that we're out of
validated targets the old ones have been
exhausted by too many new drugs that hit
the same target and many many failed new
targets have not been validated so part
of the problem is cost to take these
pills until you can't afford them
anymore so the reality is that it costs
a lot of money to develop new
medications so they have to charge a lot
of money to get that back in in an
investing world where this is privately
driven however there's a difference
between cost and value if the pill you
pills are expensive but they're not
valuable then they're not going to be
used and even if they're approved and
they're safe and effective they won't be
purchased so cost is a huge driver and
there's been a lot of bad poster boy
publications and publicity about
overcharging in pharma and this is a big
problem so they learn of objectives what
I'm going to try to do for the rest of
my talk is to first discuss the reasons
for the slowdown of innovative new
treatments entering psychopharmacology
and the
for the exit of Big Pharma largely from
psychiatry we're going to show that
future advances in our field of
psychopharmacology may indeed be based
on targeting symptoms and not disorders
particularly symptoms that cut across a
large array of psychiatric disorders
this is a paradigm shift we're also
going to propose that effective new
treatments will be based upon
subpopulations that are defined well in
the short run mostly by their symptoms
but in the long run and they certainly
want to have biomarkers that are either
genetic or neuro imaging markers so
that's the overall learning objectives
Allisyn anybody can be a brain surgeon
neuroscientist or a drug innovator it
used to be so easy before it got so hard
what's going on here well shouldn't new
drug development psychopharmacology be
easy it was easy since the 1960s when we
started it was all serendipitous they
found also two new sorts of drugs and
you know there's only 85 to 100 billion
neurons and even more Glee on the brain
that's pretty simple it's only about the
same number of neurons that are the
number of stars in the Milky Way that's
not difficult and oh they should be real
simple to relate the initial cellular
effects of a drug to the behavioral
benefit in heterogeneous patient groups
of syndromes defined by experts and not
by biology will that really be such a
difficult task who needs a functioning
clinical trial apparatus anyway and who
needs serendipity like the old times you
know
I'm one of the old timers so we used to
do that when we didn't know anything
about psychiatric disorders we didn't
even know anything about all the drugs
work we just empirically put it in
patients and they work magically it's
only afterwards we figured out how the
drugs work and and targeted it obviously
I'm being very cynical here this is the
problem we have enormous complexity and
the broken clinical trials apparatus and
we're no longer using serendipity
so we're trying to solve complex
problems with simple solutions and you
can imagine this is one of the reasons
why we're having such difficulty and
this comes from the kind of thinking
that Danny Weinberger does where the
path from jeans all the way to your
behavior goes through cells and circuits
and we're only just beginning to learn
how that is done so I think what's
happening is that we've exhausted and
basically beat like a dead horse all the
known validated targets that were
empirically found by serendipity and
then actually then you know clarified
but new targets are going to await
probably a retrenching in neurobiology
we'll begin to understand the pathway
from here to there from genes to
behavior the other thing that's
happening is that you can't just give a
drug and see if it works you've got to
know whether it hits its target and
we're starting to do that today to the
extent we have new targets or even old
ones we have ways to see that the drug
you're giving at the dose that's that's
that's provided is actually engaging the
targets because we have different
imaging markers but drug levels
affinities biomarkers various ways to
actually at least guesstimate if not
prove that there's target engagement
obviously if you have a drug is not
engaging the target it's got zero chance
of working
however the validated targets are just
filled with drugs most of which are not
generic so who's going to invent a new
drug that's an SSRI or an snri or
another atypical antipsychotic or
another benzodiazepine these targets are
old tired and multiple options for
treatment and they're all free
essentially they're generic then what
happen is Pharma realize that maybe 20
years ago and veered off course and
tried to look for new targets they look
for peptide targets they look we're
looking now for Alzheimer's targets
which are you know in in trouble right
now but what we've learned is that
Pharma is really better position to make
drugs from known targets than to
discover new targets they figured this
out now and they're on the sidelines
until we provide them
from science neuroscience and so forth
and academics we're gonna have to come
with the target side because Pharma has
finally remembered this refresh my
memory hedge comb and my research or
development farmers not research farmers
development so we don't have validated
targets for them to actually develop we
still are researching what those are and
it may be a decade or so before we get a
bunch of new validated targets well
we're on course we're getting there
so I think on the back of those new
targets will come all sorts of new drugs
but right now we don't have them we have
a lot of information technology we just
don't have any information that's sort
of what the situation is and so we're
working to fix that but you can't be
surprised if it takes a while to get
there so the other thing is that this
situation reminds me of an ant I just
saw recently in the Economist magazine I
get for a BMW and it says increases
dopamine serotonin and adrenaline and
that's just sitting still actually they
misspelled serotonin but the point is
that we have so over targeted dopamine
serotonin or adrenaline that even the
BMW advertisers know about it so I'm not
sure we're going to get any more blood
of that turnip the amount of amines
have had all the targets for our drugs
and so we need new targeting maybe there
are ways to target these things
differently or simultaneously but
basically the point of this slide is to
say we've over targeted them we need new
targets so what is the new modern
overall strategy well we don't know if
it's going to work but this is what
we're doing is what most promising and
with the smart people in our field thing
simply put its symptoms in circuits I'm
going to remind you that psychiatric
disorders aren't our syndromes there are
collections of symptoms they're defined
descriptively by
experts not neurobiologically so
shouldn't surprise you that this doesn't
correlate with the brain their
heterogeneous neurobiologically even
though depression can look the same in
two people the chances of them being
neural biologically identical even
though they're phenotypically identical
is not high the symptoms that people
have and there's multiple ones in each
syndrome hypothetically arise from six
circuits what do I mean by that
circuits that have inefficient
information processing and different
symptoms are in different circuits
because the brain is topographically
organized one part of the brain has a
duty different than another and so if
you have symptom a it's in a different
circuit generally speaking than symptom
B so if you want to improve symptom a
you have to improve the efficiency of
information processing in the circuit
that drives that at least that's the
hypothetical underpinning of this idea
the same symptom though cuts across all
sorts of psychiatric disorders so the
benefit of looking symptom based is that
you might be able to fix that symptom in
one disorder as a way of doing research
and then get a bonus because it's going
to work across all the disorders with
that symptom and that same Sixth Circuit
are involved examples of that a pain
syndrome drugs that tend to work for one
type of pain work for another
neuropathic pain particularly
fibromyalgia approach for Petach
neuralgia you know by diabetic
neuropathic pain once you have one you
get several and it's beginning to look
like if you get cognition in one you may
get cognition in others whether that's
attention the executive functioning
various ways to define that that's one
of the frontiers it's clearly evident
alright that if you improve insomnia
let's say in one disorder with the
medication you're going to improve
insomnia and another disorder not just
in pure insomnia but inside
disorders where insomnia is one of many
symptoms so that's the way it's going
it's another way of looking at it is
this psychiatric disorders are
categorical they're collections of
symptoms chosen by people self-described
experts usually they're periodically
revised by the Diagnostic and
Statistical Manual of the American
Psychiatric Association recently you
know we've come up with version 5 and
psychiatric disorders in this manual are
descriptive and reliable so that when I
say depression I mean major depressive
disorder you know what that means
because we have a common definition of
that may be wrong probably is and it's
certainly not neuro biologically related
anything about at least it's a common
vocabulary and that's mostly what it's
useful for but it certainly does not
predict treatment response or have any
prediction of the neurobiology to our
great frustration remember psychiatric
disorders are not diseases they're
disorders the second slide here relating
symptoms and psychiatric disorders is
that each psychiatric disorder likely
represents many diseases
there's not one form of major depressive
disorder one form of schizophrenia may
be Hondurans psychiatric symptoms
correlate somewhat with malfunctioning
brain circuits now it's crude and it's
oversimplifying to say that but there is
some traction there but unfortunately so
far psychiatric disorders as defined by
the DSM and by experts not by
neurobiology that wouldn't be very
surprising to say that they don't
correlate well with genotypes or bio
signatures because that's not Hollywood
to find they were defined descriptively
so thus the current diagnostic strategy
is to attempt to link symptom domains
that cut across psychiatric disorders to
in efficient information processing in
specific brain circuits then you look at
the neurotransmitters that control that
specific nerve brain circuit and tune
the circuit
more like a peacock guitar string gets
tuned and you can either block or
enhance the neurotransmitters that in
you know impale that's that circuit and
not every circuit has the same
neurotransmitter so you have different
portfolios of medications that change
different portfolios of neurotransmitter
and hopefully come to a tuning from the
circuit and the elimination of the
symptom so let's take a look at
categorical versus dimensional so here
you've got nine symptoms of major
depression by definition you've got to
have one in the middle plus four more
what's interesting is that these
symptoms very much overlap with
generalized anxiety disorders the main
difference is that in the middle is
anxiety or worry rather than going
backwards depressed mood or lack of
interest but many of the ancillary
symptoms are absolutely identical so
problems concentrating problems with
sleep problems with fatigue problems
with psychomotor is all related to the
the dimensions of psychopathology that
cut across the same disorder you've seen
them in depression names of disorders
you see them in anxiety disorders so if
you deconstruct the symptom profile of
the five to nine symptoms of depression
of your individual patient into the
specific symptoms and then you ask what
brain region is associated with that
well there's some theories this is again
oversimplification
it's obviously overlap these areas of
the brain are connected to other areas
of the brain and actually ultimately
everything is connected to each other
but there seems to be some topographical
robustness to the ventral medial
prefrontal cortex for example with
depressed mood worthlessness or guilt
and suicidal ideation perhaps in the
amygdala fatigue over here psychomotor
symptoms of the striatum you've got loss
of interest or pleasure might be both
nucleus accumbens and hypothalamus
certainly vegetative symptoms like
insomnia and weight being hypothalamus
and so forth and so on
that's problems concentrating so you can
go through all this and play this game
again oversimplification but it's the
concept that is important here and not
only is it just depression I'm going to
quickly go through two other
schizophrenia it could be deconstructed
as well into five major domains if you
wish positive negative cognitive
affective aggressive essentially and
guess what they live in different
circuits so we think and if you have to
look at that you could match each
symptom to its hypothetically
malfunctioning brain circuit negative
symptoms may be more in the miserable
cortical area cognitive symptoms dorsal
lateral prefrontal cortex orbital
frontal and for an amygdala for
aggressive affective ventral medial
prefrontal and the cognitive symptoms
mesolimbic again oversimplification but
you would not expect all symptoms to get
better if he fixed one circuit and you
wouldn't expect one symptom to get
better no matter what circuit you fixed
so that's the idea is topographical
organization of the brain and trying to
improve the efficiency of information
processing ADHD is the third example of
that issue you know Kenya both selective
inattention and problems with sustained
attention can actually be the
inattentive symptoms but you also have
impulsive symptoms and you have a
hyperactive symptoms now do you think
hyperactivity is in the same part of the
brain that impulsivity is no you think
paying attention is in the same part of
the brain you're moving your limbs too
much is of course not that even make any
sense so you would expect that at least
there would be different circuits and if
the dorsal lateral prefrontal cortex is
a good candidate for sustained attention
and problem-solving executive
functioning the orbital frontal cortex
is a good area that is linked to
impulsive symptoms of course it's
connected to other downstream and also
subcortical structures in each case of
course the prefrontal motor cortex would
be a great candidate for motor symptoms
of hyperactivity and maybe the dorsal
anterior cingulate attention we're still
mapping these off these are over
together over simplifications
to reductionistic but it begins to put
some it's turning us in psychiatry
increasing into neurologists in a little
certain way so here is then the summary
of what I've been talking about where
we'd actually did a big paradigm shift
in the past we looked at depressed mood
loss of interest problems concentrating
and insomnia and said okay this is a
syndrome these four things put together
are what major depressive disorder
according to the DSM then you go over
here anxiety and worry irritability
problems concentrating and insomnia now
all of a sudden this is called
generalized anxiety disorder well look
at that two of the four symptoms overlap
and the next one inattention impulsivity
problems concentrating we've seen that
before and hyperactivity that would be
ADHD so moving in the downward direction
this is the classical DSM approach okay
categorical and however the going across
is the dimensional or the domains and
although our doc or research domain
criteria to some people's delight and
other people's are absolutely
aggravation it's just one way of doing
it but the concept that you move
problems concentrating problems
concentrating problems concentrating if
you fixed it in one domain and one
disorder would it cut across and so
we're increasingly looking at doing it
that way and so the dimensional versus a
categorical is what you're going to hear
a lot about this is what it means so the
next paradigm shift away from syndromes
to domains is moving from micro circuits
to macro circuits in the old days you
talked about the if you will the
classical synapse I mean I write these
open books everybody has the sit ups in
every book or you wouldn't be a
card-carrying psychopharmacologist
however this is a little bit dated so a
micro circuit I'm using that turn to Mia
the synapse because it's just a small
thing everybody know you know how
neurotransmitters synthesize then it's
stored and then it's released and then
it dances on receptors has a good time
and after it causes downstream effects
on neurotransmission the
neurotransmitter is either degraded or
it's taken back up into the presynaptic
neuron you live happily ever after
drugs work on this and people talk about
in this case if my little icon is
serotonin you talked about Stewart
energy synapse as though there's one in
the brain or that everyone's the same
and it is true that when you give a drug
that acts along let's say this reuptake
from which is of course famous for being
you know part of the SSRI so in this
pump over here is where serotonin
reactive you know works if that if that
SSRI is acting it's like taking the
brain and dunking it into a bucket of
serotonin it's not very specific
everywhere there's a pump the drugs
gonna work so that's pretty amazing so
what we have done though is moved away
from that very over-simplistic port of
view of just these synapse as though
there's one or they're all the same that
micro circuit if you will two macro
circuits so the old-fashioned way is
serotonin and generic synapse we got
away with that for a long time we're
able to event SSRIs it worked a lot of
big drugs came out the generic dopamine
etc but now the modern is not serotonin
in generic synapse for example in that
analogy it would be where's the
serotonin which receptor for the
serotonin and most importantly what are
the downstream effects of that serotonin
in that area of the brain or in others
so that is beginning to them look at
macro circuits that we're talking about
having inefficient information
processing in so again let's take the
serotonin example and show how it
complicated this can be no wonder we're
having a hard time finding your drugs
you can take this simple situation but
even the simple situation where now
serotonin has gone from the synapse
after being released to dancing in all
these different
14 in this case different subtypes of
serotonin receptor but some of these
earns excitatory and some of these are
inhibitory so what is the net net net
well don't you think that depends on the
concentration of serotonin the
sensitivity of those receptors and
exactly the density of the individual
receptors in one part of the brain may
be different than the density of that
same receptor in another part of the
brain completely changing maybe whether
this is an excitatory or inhibitory
signal for example so you have serotonin
circuits again so I sort of you've seen
this kind of idea but serotonin doesn't
go everywhere in the brain it overlaps
that same with norepinephrine to some
but not everywhere don't mean some but
not everywhere so it's probably not only
going to different circuits but it's
going to different sites in the same
circuit so it wouldn't surprise you that
it would have different effects in
different parts of the brain and it
would have surprised you that it would
serotonin regulation of circuits who me
different than dopamine's so it's not
just as simple as saying serotonin quote
in the brain so let's take a look at
what serotonin is like in reality if you
look at your famous Bobby HT so or
serotonin cell body and say where does
it go well it kind of comes back onto
itself and it goes downstream on the
horizontal axis and that was about as
far do they ever wet but as you know
very well that when you're trying to do
drug development you're going to hit
every receptor in the brain for that at
that particular target no matter where
it is so you better know a little bit
what's happening to your serotonin and
it looks like this so you have all these
kinds of branching outputs of serotonin
into in this case the prefrontal cortex
as if that were complicated and up it
goes lots of other places it can go down
here and talk to the locus coeruleus and
impact the release of noradrenaline
norepinephrine and of course
norepinephrine is going to come right
back up to the top here and it's going
to influence the serotonin output so the
serotonin is going to affect our
adrenaline here and our adrenaline
in effect the serotonin here and if you
then look at keeping on going you end up
having serotonin out talking to dopamine
the VTA it's going to talk to histamine
and the to Beryl memories of this is
going to talk to the basal forebrain and
cholinergic fibers and so it's quite
clear that there's talk in both
directions and again serotonin is
talking to acetylcholine and that's the
Colleen's talking to serotonin but now
we're going to put it a glutamate little
list look at this it's getting even more
complicated so serotonin is going to be
acting through glutamate as an
intermediary littermate will indirectly
influence all these neurotransmitters
either at their terminals or possibly at
their cell bodies and then just one more
layer complexity of course you have
gamma matter Jake interneurons these
purple things that change the polarity
so you have direct input through
glutamate is excitatory but if you have
glutamate talking to gaba before it goes
downstream it's going to change the
polarity to be inhibition these are
general concepts we all know abut the
idea is what circuit are you trying to
manage is that the glutamate output from
a pyramidal neuron in the prefrontal
cortex which is out of tune perhaps and
then gets tuned by these gaba and all
these colorful model energy inputs and
how would we discover what's wrong where
it's wrong and how to fix it
that's the state of the art right now
that has to be answered before we're
going to have new innovations we need to
know that it's complicated but I'm going
to show you another level of
complication because here serotonin
receptors regulate glutamate release
both directly on the left and I'll show
you in a moment indirectly on the right
so here you have serotonin coming in and
what it's doing is it's talking directly
to glutamate and you see all the
receptors at the top and what it's doing
is
talking to the the 5-ht to see that's
five fifty four five six seven there's a
582 a here that the five you want in
here oh my goodness and what are the net
nets of this well I guess it kind of
depends on you know whether it's
excitatory inhibitory and indeed if you
look here serotonin is going to come out
so there's a little cloud of serotonin
and guess what
it could have inhibitory effect here it
can have excitatory effects here it can
have net-net is it going to increase or
decrease the release of glutamate down
here so I guess it depends glutamate
going to go up or down and stimulate the
downstream knock-on neurotransmitters
that we're talking about for adoro from
serotonin
can you see obviously increasing
serotonin is not enough you say well
I've increased serotonin but you know so
what what does that mean that's not
enough where what's the net net and you
know it depends on the density receptor
of course so let's go ahead and look at
what happens if the regulation of
downstream released by directly Hubbell
down over here
serotonin can go to the very same
receptors but if they're decorated on to
gabem energy interneurons as shown here
guess what if you excite inhibition you
actually are inhibitory so if you excite
excitation you're excitatory oh my gosh
you're getting obviously a headache here
I'm teasing but but you see this
glutamate can go up if the nut nut is
excitation but it could also go down if
the net-net of the serotonin talking to
these various excitatory
neurotransmitters to make gather go up
and therefore you have if you well
perhaps reduction of glutamate and this
glutamate could have profound effects on
downstream action and we're all very
interested in what luta mate does these
days and lots of different disorders and
so this is begins to get an idea of a
little bit of the complexity so when I
teach doctors give me about about
neurotransmitter
these days I try to say look I don't
care if you know the specifics of this
next cartoon I'm going to show you but
it's the concept I went to the grass so
we have zero to 180 receptors I just
choose one of them I could choose any of
the 14 but let's say you have a drug
that acts on this receptor now serotonin
acts on all this receptors let's say
you've done specific antagonist agonist
partial agonist at this receptor the
postsynaptic ones
versions are located in various areas of
the brain we know they regulate
glutamate the prefrontal cortex they
regulate dopamine and ask the choline
norepinephrine and well I'll show you in
a bit and so we know that at least the
postsynaptic one seemed to be possibly
reduced in patients with depression but
they don't down regulate with
antidepressants and a person is down
regulate the presynaptic version but
this is some of the things we know about
the postsynaptic so here we got an
increase in dopamine I'll pull it in the
prefrontal cortex by selectively 5-ht
one a a gibbous here's a little rat
there's this brain on the right and on
the bottom you've got basically a
baseline of the dopamine output right
right here so now let's say what we're
going to do we're going to move forward
and we're going to give a 5h t18 agonist
over here and inject it in the rat now
let's look and see what's going to
happen over here even though we're
giving a funny - you want any agonist
look what happens to dopamine okay
dopamine is going to go up up up and
then it goes up over here and on the
graph and it's going up over here and
what we have is basically a serotonin
agonist changing dopamine how does it do
that in a circuit and let take a quick
look at that circuit
it could be driven in part by the 5h t1a
receptors that are in the cortex because
we know that stimulation of those
increases striatal dopamine release and
has certain implications for
extrapyramidal symptoms but I'm not
really going to talk about well let's
take a look you see the top box up here
is blown up on the right at the bottom
and the bottom box
on that and the brain is blown up on the
left so let me push the button go
forward and you see serotonin has
actually come out hasn't it right here
and it's talking to a five ht1 a
receptor and look what's going to happen
next
it's going to inhibit this glutamate
neuron and the color I'm gonna show goes
out so right here it goes
out and now look at the Box on the left
it's going to come down they're
continuing that same neuron if glutamate
doesn't get released it doesn't make
gaba go up in that tiny little neuron
that's right here you see right there
and if that does not get activated then
dopamine is no longer inhibited it is
basically at this point disinhibited and
guess what it turns blue and you have
release of dopamine up here in the
cortex and you live happily ever after
maybe but the idea is that dopamine will
then go up so this seems to be the
mechanism or at least a hypothetical
plausible mechanism at least in some
systems of how stimulated in the body
ht1 a receptor through several transom
optic actions goes around and around and
changes dopamine release so you could
imagine that if your dope needs to
higher too low this could be modified
that you could actually change the
efficiency of information processing
let's say here in the striatum because
you have more dopamine that's either
good or bad thing depending on the
situation but the point is just that
this is not just dopamine in the brain
it's not just serotonin in the brain
it's quite receptor where receptor and
what the downstream effects are so new
drug development has to take account of
that and this kind of finish this
briefly you see that in this case we've
got our 581 a receptor once again and in
this case it's talking to a gambling
energic inner neuron and it's going to
inhibit that neuron we're talking to and
that gamma nergic neurons is talking to
the terminal of a noradrenergic neuron
over here and this this gap is going to
be talking to the terminal of a
dopaminergic neuron here and then
finally you've got
this gabaergic neuron talking to a
cholinergic neuron here so why do you
care because if you look at this and you
have serotonin go up at the top it's
going to inhibit gaba
if gaba is inhibited it's going to go
down and that down is going to
disinhibitor and you saw that the purple
cloud got bigger basically 5-ht want a
stimulation increased in this case
norepinephrine let's do it now for
dopamine that will go down no more
inhibition so the blue goes up and then
finally the last one would be north
because of the way this is wired so the
wiring diagram in the brain is such that
at least some systems you can show that
by vg1 a stimulation leads to downstream
increase of these three
neurotransmitters so this is something
you want to desire to tune the circuit
this might be how you did it at least in
some circuits other circuits may have
different rules now we're going to move
on and say beyond the circuits can we
actually look at them and the answer is
yes
because we can digitally enhance them
with our neuro imaging so it's not just
about what the circuits are can we
actually see them performing can we see
them consuming oxygen can we see them
pixelating brains and yes
congratulations mr. Grimshaw you've been
digitally enhanced from a mean old
bastard to delightful old codger
so that's neuro imaging and we can show
them an example of the kind of thing
that the problem with this is the the
sizes of these changes are only a few
percent changes in neuronal firing the
other is that they don't obviously the
same in different machines in different
places and they're hard to replicate so
I'm not saying this particular one which
I just chose around them is the way it's
going to be but it's the idea of how it
might be so what you do is you put
somebody's head in a scanner they're
alive and they're doing this group task
and the Stroop task it's a look at these
colored words and you have to say the
color and this is pretty easy because
you would say red but over here this
group task you'd want to kind of be
tempted to read it and say Ratigan but
that'd be wrong response because it
collected correct response here is blue
now when you do that task normally
you'll see here
that the dorsal lateral prefrontal
cortex I'm sorry the the inter cingulate
lights up a little bit in a normal
person and a touch of of this is normals
right vo PFC so this is a part of the
brain that actually performs a task you
have to call in a psychiatric treadmill
like us the cardiologist gets them on a
treadmill and there's a stress test you
want to stress the brain you can do the
strip test and see which part of the
brain performs it well what if you're
depressed you'll get hyperactivity in
the anterior cingulate and now in the
left dorsal lateral prefrontal cortex at
least in this study and again whether
this gets replicated or these are robust
findings I'm not even talking about but
here this is way too big
and instead what you got here is this
very weird you know extra brain is going
so what's happened well I guess one
explanation is that major depressive
disorder subjects recruited extra areas
of the brain are overworked similar
areas of the brain to perform the same
task now that looks like inefficient
information processing and you'd want
those areas of the brain to not be
working over too hard you want them to
normalize with the hope that this is
going to then normalize symptoms that's
the underlying theory now we move from
neural imaging to genetics marry me
Virginie of my genes are excellent and
as yet unpatented so what do we mean
about this
well obviously genetics has gotten
complicated when I actually was in the
my training last century we actually
thought there might be a gene for
schizophrenia or a gene for depression
when we we don't know that's crazy idea
there's no will be a gene for these
things and then we kind of moved to
thinking well maybe there are portfolios
of gene each which has a certain amount
of the variance and but they're abnormal
they're they're single nucleotide
polymorphisms well that doesn't seem to
be even the case it sounds like
psychiatric disorders are not just
caused by abnormal genes they're caused
by normal genes but the normal genes are
FPE genetically dysregulated meaning
maybe they're on when they should be off
or off when they should be on that's
just as devastating as having an
abnormal gene and it's
and furthermore epigenetics is is
changed by the environment by drugs by
aging by diet all sorts of things so
this is the nature-nurture interactions
played out upon one's DNA and the
regulation of whether this DNA is
expressed is a big part of psychiatric
disorders today and furthermore it
doesn't even have to be expressed as a
protein it could only be expressed as a
micro RNA and be enough to actually have
profound implications for psychiatric
disorders and here we a say why it's not
a cure doesn't mean a guaranteed income
for me so this has a an implication for
whether we're going to have no drug
company early wants to cure you nobody
wants to give you a one dose drug that
could work you don't make a lot of money
from that so there there is this
conflict between trying to make drugs
that are symptomatic relief that don't
they can be stopped as opposed to drugs
that need to be taken for a lifetime so
we can to look a little bit more on the
drugs at being taking more often for
economic reasons we actually don't think
that you know we can do a lot of the
other ones anyway but we we have a
question about whether we should give
symptomatic or disease-modifying and
almost all of our disorders of course
are just symptomatic improvements but
symptom suppression in psychiatry what
0.0 quickly doesn't have the same
meaning that it does in other areas of
Medicine you know I you know I trained
as a physician we're told shortness of
breath
isn't a symptom you should treat just on
the top of that you should go down and
find the underlying cause and treat that
and then the shortness of breath so get
better but in in psychiatry it could
very well be different because the
symptom may be the disease not a lot
growth of it in other words suppression
of symptoms may be the goal directly
because it seems only to improve your
psychosocial functioning but it in
itself could potentially prevent disease
progression this remains to be proven
but it seems to be a plausible way of
looking at it so we're more and more
interested in
early recognition I tell my residents
it's not merely merciful to stop
somebody from suffering from their
symptoms it may be good for the brain
because being mentally ill is not fun
but it's also probably bad for your
brain so early recognition could
potentially prevent wrecking the brain
underneath it because we don't want
symptoms to progress if we were really
lucky even try even pre-symptomatic
treatments but that's hard because you
have to be sure exactly how that you
know you don't wanna get people
medicines they don't need them expose
them to expense and risk and side
effects and so we don't have good ways
to know who's going to become a patient
of schizophrenia or who's going to
relapse necessarily so this will be you
know we need to know about disease
mechanisms to actually have drugs for
that or we already know already
practicing psychiatrist is pretty clear
to those of us who do that that
aggressive early treatment to prevent
disease progression because one of the
forms of disease progression which is
terrible in my practice everyday is
treatment resistance and treatment
resistance seems to be related to the
number of episodes you had the number of
symptoms you continued to have between
episodes and it may be partly related to
crappy-ass 8 of under treatment of
psychiatric disorders and allowing them
to persist for too long and their
symptoms to only be partially improved
so in other words tell me do you respond
to treatment what are on the horizon for
new drug development well we need drugs
for patients or treatment resistance we
don't need first-line drugs drug
companies tend to want to make drugs for
everybody because they see the size of
the market and they want to make sure
that they can give it to everybody but
the realities of the huge unmet need for
treatment resistance it's more valuable
so that if the drugs are going to be
expensive does this may be worth it if
the early drugs don't work another way
of saying it is that the first-line
treatments for many disorders in sakai q
are largely satisfied depression anxiety
if you know it's good for eating for
example so what's the unmet need the
unmet need is when these guys don't work
now what do you do well that's what I do
for a living they try to combine drugs
do fantasy stop changing focus but but
we really needed as drugs of new
mechanisms because maybe the mechanism
isn't going to answer that particular
person whose symptom so we need either
treatment resistant medication or
symptoms that can be treated in some
cases but not all or treatments where
there's none at all for example the
cognitive symptoms of schizophrenia
since they have no treatment the
cognitive and behavioral symptoms of
dementia have little if any treatment
the cognitive symptoms of depression are
only starting to have treatment
substance abuse huge problem essentially
no medical treatment so any innovation
in these areas would be hugely valuable
and there's a lot of suggestion that the
frontier of neurobiology is actually
right at this place I'll talk briefly
about cognition and substance abuse in
another slide so first cognition if you
had remembered what I told you last time
you wouldn't have amnesia
well cognition is a big part of lots of
things I mean I told you problems
concentrating is ADHD problems
concentrating is generalized anxiety
disorder problems concentrating is major
depressive disorder
certainly dementia well we have a rich
translational neurobiological foundation
for exploring how we can move from
animal studies of cognitive and
cognitive disorders into humanism and it
could even be things like impulsivity
and compulsivity which are maybe a
product of not having enough top-down
cognitive control other ideas about
domains of cognition where we need to
look our attention executive dysfunction
now executive dysfunction is really
problem solving it doesn't mean say
Donald Trump or something like that
that's not that's a different form of
executive dysfunction
bad job or a CEO of a drug company it
might be executive dysfunction that's
not what I'm talking about I'm talking
about problem solving in a certain way
and there are multiple domains of neural
cognition that can work you may know
that in sauna clean is an alpha 7
nicotinic partial agonist and it's in
late stage development for schizophrenia
in Alzheimer's disease
has some promise is a pro cognitive drug
by that mechanism another promising
agent is lordy oxy teen and it has
recently gotten claims for improving
better than normal manner depressants
just the cognitive domain of depression
in Europe and the US FDA is working on
language to see how they're going to
actually evaluate this I think there's
an FDA advisory board coming up very
quickly there's also five HT six
antagonists that are going to be you
know look like they have promised in
Alzheimer's disease for symptomatic
treatment look Pro cholinergic and maybe
neural plastic how about other promising
areas substance abuse well this might be
and that I've told you know my own
crystal ball is that this might be the
big explosion of innovation in the next
decade animal models of schizophrenia
may not be good animal models of
depression may not be good but some
animal models may be relatively good
translational foundation for substance
abuse an addicted rat may be closer to
an addicted human than schizophrenic rat
to a schizophrenic human huge unmet need
my god look at all the opiate problems
and teenagers that start with
prescription opiates and transfer into
heroin it's just awful and we're making
rapid neurobiological progress to
understand that and the other thing is
that we can possibly recirculate
discarded drugs from other developmental
programs with big pharma take them off
the shelf and look at them particularly
you know as you all know those you look
at this area or glutamate mechanisms but
there are several drugs out there that
maybe could be recycled and used in this
area and then maybe to try to track some
pharma into this another potential area
is inflammatory its tends to have been
left out of psychiatry we don't actually
have drugs that specifically targets
like Africa disorders by
anti-inflammatory mechanism but we
believe that there's all sorts of
inflammation going on in mood disorders
and lots of other disorders
stress-related disorders and why is that
interesting because it's a future
prospect to change immune dysregulation
in the brain
and psychiatric disorders there's an
increasing role of immune reckon his
immense I kept it disorders and there
are brain easily thought to be Haven
where there wasn't much you know
immunologically going on because all
that action is outside the brains not a
little true and there are potential new
targets all sorts of them inside the
brain for this and we can piggyback onto
advances that are occurring in other
therapeutic areas because of
inflammatory anti-inflammatory
approaches we can just use those same
drugs that they get into the brain we
can maybe use them there so at the end
of the day ladies again we want everyone
to say our psychopharmacologist is a
genius and to say psychopharmacology is
not yet innovation is not gone it's
retrenching it's trying again we're
changing the paradigm we're changing the
strategies so in conclusion I will say
the innovation in psychopharmacology is
retrenching awaiting a solution to
problems is critical trials methodology
I generally talk much about that but it
is a problem which is being addressed by
different methods and we're also looking
which I talk a lot more about about how
to validate new targets the approach my
prediction is based upon like money
crystal ball and the argument I've just
made is that the approach will likely
target symptoms in inefficiently
functioning neural circuits that
underlie the symptom that you want to
get better and when you do that those
symptoms could be potentially treated
because they cut across numerous
psychiatric conditions many psychiatric
disorders have at least one of the same
symptoms eventually I think we will get
to the point where biomarkers from
genetics and neuroimaging will subtype
people yeah and along the
neurobiological basis but I don't think
it's going to happen tomorrow so this is
something that is you know something
that's on the horizon so I hope you've
enjoyed this has been fun speculating
about it I thank the organizers for
asking me to talk on this subject and I
think I'll turn it back over to our
moderator thank you very much
thank you dr. stall for that informative
presentation you can email me questions
about this presentation at SMS tah at
AEI global.com
I would also like to thank our sponsor
and our technology for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing until September 2016
you'll receive an email from lab reading
you know when this webcast will be
available to replay please share the
announcement with your colleagues to
manage today's live event that's all for
now thank you for joining us and we hope
to see you again soon bye